how did it go
oh I see it it's bad all right next one
from Binney yeah [ __ ]
what's up vlog it's gonna be a wacky day
here I don't know how much shouldn't be
able to film not a whole lot just feels
like it's the story of Batman's life
alright let's do a couple questions
right here right now
let me just give you guys a sense of
what I'm doing to just to bring a little
value like I'm just trying to really
bring us more a little more value to the
blog got a one-on-one meeting right now
with somebody pretty important in
business to can't get anything here just
you know classic our meeting where I'm
there's so much of what you know I know
this for a long time ago somebody posted
something about the blog and like you
don't do anything you know like what the
[ __ ] you just travel around and like
have meetings and like [ __ ] you when I
was like I'm just laughing about this
next meeting to me an hour meeting it's
gonna be a meeting it's be a
relationship building its power
brokering it's a you know just who do
you think is smart who do you think is
doing interesting things actually I
think we were able to show a little bit
of this meeting which is nice because
now I gave her a huge DAP so just like
who do you think smart who do you
think's doing interesting stuff and that
is worth your hour because you might be
able to provide that person value and
then that's in the ethos and Karma's
practical for me there's no bigger
strategy on earth then provide as much
value as possible to everybody and then
there's an extra kicker if you can
provide value to the 3 to 4 percent of
the winners in society without any
expectation because you understand if
somebody's a three to four percent
winner in society their whole life as
somebody who lives that life and like to
think that he's getting into that zone
every single meeting is somebody asking
you for something so the off-speed pitch
the complete curveball if I could spend
more time having meetings with people
that are playing at the top three four
percent of the world in their crafts and
genres that I'm interested in and the
entire meeting is me providing value for
them well then I would be set for the
next five decades in my career
so that's that it's nice little rant on
that and then I have a meeting at Apple
Shh and then I have who go to
vaynermedia LA meet with a bunch of
one-on-ones and catch up with people and
then I've got a meeting with Shh and
then I've got a meeting with Shh
one meeting is with some other taste
makers and other ones with potential
client none of it can be shown so let's
get into the QA all right first one from
Linda dawn mm-hmm
hey Linda when you know your day is
going to be crazy how do you mentally
prepare yourself for it every day of my
life is crazy
um I'm busy and if you mean crazy like
look that's not fair all my days are
crazy by regular standards but above and
beyond for me like everybody's got their
baseline you know just uh to me I I use
perspective when I've got to do things
that I'm not looking forward to like
going to the dentist is for me like
crazy you know you know things like that
so just perspective you know like I
could be terminally ill it's kind of
where I go somewhere people I care about
could be terminally ill so just putting
things in perspective like you know I
also think that you've made your bed
you've signed up for this like I hate
when people do well or complain about
[ __ ] when it's the infrastructure
they've created for themselves like
you've picked that job you decided to
start this startup you signed with that
manager you decided to create this
business you've decided to put yourself
out there like I'm a big fan of I've
signed up for it so I got to eat it
that's next one from Laura Alisa what
are your thoughts on content marketing
and also what marketing strategy for
major businesses do you see in most
successful considering the generation
and current I'm just telling the person
I'm 10 minutes late
one more time named flora flora what are
your thoughts on content marketing and
basically what's the best marketing
strategy for major businesses to do
into this generation I mean I think
content market content is the variable
of success so I think it's oxygen I mean
I don't think if you're not producing
content you're not relevant now content
can be broken down a lot of ways a lot
of people a lot of businesses back to
your question are making content in the
form of commercials and marketing I
think that's a bad idea for the most
part I think there's a new age of
content that can be produced that is far
more storytelling compelling don't make
a commercial make a movie trailer to
sell your product that kind of thinking
so I think every business needs to think
more like a media company I hae a Volvo
needs to think more like ESPN Conde Nast
you know CBS News Steven Spielberg than
they need to think about making a Volvo
commercial right so I think that a what
do I think about it I think it's the
cost of entry of success in today's
environment if you make it in the form
of content and information entertainment
not in the form of a commercial or a
sales pitch that is the biggest
differentiator and that's how I think
about it you should start a podcast for
a million dollars instead of spending a
million dollars in radio ads and that's
where big businesses are getting caught
hi sorry thank you
come on
thank you oh listen you got you got my
back here I'm happy to help
all right nice to meet you man take care
of it it was cool right
so I found three that are kind of weird
let's do it cool house the first one for
Christopher
by the way blog I'm so pumped up about
this like I literally think this can
become the vlog like backseat answers
alright go ahead
Christopher um is there any strategy for
farmers other than direct marketing
meeting produce my family raises
commodities like corn soy beans etc
margins suck and it feels pointless or
current ROI of such a huge investment
love this nerdy question big shout out
to all the farmers that have been such a
foundation of this incredible country
but the world evolves right and so
farming wants the technology industry of
our society no longer to your point
brother what's his name again
Christopher Chris Christopher I get it
and so here's what I would say if I was
the son of a farmer um was that mine was
that my head Pete if I was in that game
who's that my head piece about yeah
let's leave this in the vlog
I think it's really funny anyway Oh bro
if I was in that business I would start
small and I would start a brand right
like if you're producing corn all right
if you're producing corn like four
carrots or cabbage like start a very
small direct-to-consumer brand in that
space make the capital investment to
those those kind of business models so
yeah I think that there's an incredible
opportunity for you in starting a very
small direct consumer brand call it
Christopher's corn like Bobbie Robbins
beef jerky and away you go and so yeah I
think that's the strategy like started
direct to consumer consumer packaged
goods foods brands started very small
make a thousand bucks the first year I
don't care
eventually I may eventually you could
become Jolly Green Giant if you do it
right you're making this stuff the
margin is with the people that know how
to market it and sell it figure out how
to build those capabilities start small
farm stands and Shopify in Amazon and
take it from there
how did it go oh I see it it's bad all
right next one from Binney yeah
[ __ ] all right can you ask Gary
any advice for me publicly door-to-door
sales specifically I'm secure sorry
first of all babban you were evolving
into a great teammate these are great
niche questions that don't normally get
answered and this is the this is the
foundation of back seat answers with
Gary any back seat answers BSA well you
know I think that there's a lot of
thoughts I have one door-to-door sales
men you know I think doing your homework
is very important so for example if you
know that you're gonna be in Edison New
Jersey and that's where you sell I would
go to Twitter and search Edison New
Jersey and see what people are talking
about you know if somebody if somebody
says Sam darn 'old yeah like I would
have when I was in Edison New Jersey
when you roll up and you make a darn old
reference or you deliver a Sam d'Arnaud
t-shirt or something that nature I think
people could use Twitter search in the
radius that they're selling door-to-door
some people may think it's creepy but
you start with like hey I'm a I'm an you
know if you do to do hello hey I'm a New
Wave door-to-door salesman I use Twitter
to make it awesome I saw that you're a
Jets fan here's a little Sam darn old
t-shirt you know but now you're home
security sucks like that just wild
that's different you know now you may
get the mom who answers the door and she
doesn't know what you're talking about
the Twitter thing but like look
technology has allowed us to know more
about the people we're selling to I
think one door-to-door sales even the
people that win the most have humility
you know I would if I was door-to-door
sales today I would knock and I would
say look I know you don't want me here
you're busy very simply I think you're
overpaying for your home security like
something that would be literally my
pension so I think door to door does too
much sizzle and not enough steak this is
like hey you know I would go reverse
brother I would go humility be like I
know you don't want me here you're busy
I appreciate you even opening the door
you're overpaying for your home security
system
[ __ ] technology that just door-to-door
sales my [ __ ] concepts more humility
less hyperbole
[Music]
last one this guy runs a snake breeding
business if you ran that business how
you are good I would make a ton of
content if your snake breeding you
[ __ ] won in today's world like visual
content for days like just incredible I
would also run heavy heavy ads on
YouTube pre-roll based on google
searching so people searching snakes
snake breathing then they go watch a
Gary Vee video but the first three
seconds is a snake breeding video and
you're into that pre-roll YouTube based
on search query capabilities on YouTube
is one of the incredible ad products in
the world and how they recommend that
you do that if you're a snake breeder
if I bought the company tomorrow and
have the bucket of money for two videos
one anthem video the way you wanted it
one the way I wanted it a one-week or
wherever else and social media ads to
drive business and and the pairs that
we've allocated to the influencers if
they all started at the starting point
that we are at now I would probably take
50 cents on a dollar from all the other
buckets and put it into giving out Morse
to post on Instagram because I genuinely
believe that would sell the most amount
and build the most amount of brand give
me the the actual number I will
personally Wednesday night with with my
team put all these ideas over a four
hour period line by line for two pop-ups
when he comes through like literally
lying for line like you know for podcast
integration because I'll hit up like I
will literally line by line breakdown
the most comprehensive Culture Media
plan you've ever seen I just want to
make sure that I have every dollar and
that when I give it to you those were
the dollars and then all you'll have to
do is say yes or no and then we can
[ __ ] roll
yep yep how are you good
hey oh hey what's up Judy well I'm gonna
start because I don't want to hold up
too much time so thanks for getting
together hello I have a couple
announcements that I want to walk
through and then let me just hang for
ten minutes and maybe ask any answer any
questions anybody may have on any of the
things going on so we have some pretty
exciting announcements
[Music]